I baked a Sehun is busy packing her
nursing supplies a first-aid box blood
pressure monitor medicine everything she
needs to give a course about
reproductive health to former migrants
women who returned to their native
Ethiopia after suffering trauma abroad
some are literally from having some
personal record of health problems so I
can't go there and teach them how to use
these protective materials and this
thing half today sir progressed it at
home and told obey works for live at us
a non-governmental organization that
helps vulnerable people in Ethiopia many
of them are women who left Ethiopia in
search of a better life and were
bitterly disappointed the organization
offers the women training and helps them
find work back home a base job is to
provide medical and psychological help
the woman she's meeting today have
returned from Arab countries so are -
say whom worked in Lebanon for two years
and later in the United Arab Emirates
she says both of her employers were crew
my father died when I was young I left
school and decided to go to the Middle
East but nothing comforted me there some
women like mascara bearer have been
through terrifying experiences she
worked in Lebanon's capital Beirut her
pay was nowhere near enough to live on
and that wasn't it her worst problem I
enjoyed many challenges but the sexual
harassment from my employers son was too
much for me a base as many women
returned to Ethiopia with sexually
transmitted diseases they want to start
a new life but don't know how and then
migrated illegally and they returned
empty-handed they have some
psychological problem and health related
problems like healthy family planning
matters I've learnt loss I didn't know
about condom usage and preventing
sexually transmitted diseases obey has
helped a great deal one person is
missing from the meeting
obey and another woman from the group
decide to visit her they arrive at the
home of the 28 year old woman who gave
birth to weeks ago Elena sir ham worked
in the United Arab Emirates for four
years when asked what happened to her
she just says never again it's very
important to us in for them to know
their current status what happened to
them this is our obligation to follow
them whether they are asking us or not
it takes time for the women to open up
that's why a bay is always on call she
believes the women can only heal their
psychological wounds if they know
someone is there for them at any time of
day